Neuberg: So within
your career, what are one of
the one or two things
that you're really proud of
in the sense of what
you were just talking about.
Marks: The things
I'm proud of is where
looking at something
and sort of simplifying
and clarifying it, um,
can make some sense,
and that that can have
a broader impact.
So the stuff
with microformats,
where we basically said,
"Whoa, couldn't we just
use HTML to represent data?
Why do need to define
something else?"
And then take that constraint
and work that through.
That was nice.
Or the work with OpenSocial,
where we said,
"Here's a lot of people
doing the same thing.
"but they're not talking
to each other.
"Can we make them
talk to each other
and standardize that?"
I'm very excited about that.
But it's--those are the things
that are harder to point at
and say, "You're running
my code."
It's much more these days
of, "Here's a bunch of ideas
that I've helped catalyze
and fit together."
And I, you know, I can't
take credit for
all the focus,
all the organization
in any respect at all.
But if I've been part
of helping people
to converse and connect
about that,
that's what I'm proud of.
He--he was a lovely guy.
He was very, very, you know,
very, very smart,
very interesting to talk to.
Um, he's--and I still keep
citing him.
He wrote this wonderful piece
in 1999 about the internet
that I just cannot resist
citing at every opportunity
because he got so much right.
To some extent, he was--
he was living in the future
because--I suppose
partly because
he had more money to spend
on technology
than most people had.
But he wrote a whole bunch
of things saying,
"Why is it we have to use
cables for everything?"
And "Why does everything
have a different
power supply" and stuff.
Which, if you look at now,
we have Bluetooth and Wi-Fi.
We have standardized
USB charge.
We have a whole bunch
of stuff like that,
and there's the stuff
that he wrote, you know,
10, 15 years ago that was
pointing out
the problems
with the technology,
and--but in a witty
and funny way
that made people stop
and think about it.
And if you actually sit there
and watch live TV,
the only reason
you're watching live TV
is you're waiting
for something to happen.
So you're watching baseball,
and most of it is boring,
and there's a few little bits
where it's exciting.
Or you're watching--you know,
the Presidential election
waiting for the outcome.
Or you're watching
some news thing.
And the live bits of this
are generally
people filling dead air waiting
for something to happen.
Saying, "Well, I expect
somebody's gonna come out
of the car soon."
And I began to realize
that this was actually
a recipe for, you know,
a lot of stuff that isn't
very interesting.
The thing that is interesting
about live
is when it's two-way.
That's the only time
you actually need it.
And I think the same
problem runs through
lots of these media,
is that we see them as
simulacra of previous media.
And that leads to two traps.
One trap is
it then becomes a battle.
When is blogging
going to replace newspapers?
Which is this boring debate
that's been going on
for ten years.
And then, but you also get
this problem
that you're trying
to model something else.
That can be useful.
You know, Wikipedia is trying
to model an encyclopedia.
That gives a context
that means that
the edits can work
in that way.
But it also sets up conflicts
like the deletionist/
inclusionist debate
of, "Well, this isn't
important enough
"to be in the encyclopedia.
We should delete it."
As opposed to, "Well,
it's a database.
"How--you know,
what are you wasting
by putting something
that nobody goes to?"
A sort of software
development cultural change
I've seen in my lifetime,
which is--
You know, I was doing
CD-ROM development.
Now with CD-ROM development,
you're making little
shiny silver discs
that you press a million of
and you sell to people.
And so the model has to be
lots of lots of upfront
design testing and QA.
Then you press these things
and go out to try to sell them.
The difference is
now with the web
we can dynamically develop.
We can build something,
put it out there,
see if it works,
measure it--
you know, control it,
iterate, try variations
and keep moving from that.
So we've got a software
development process now
that is much more
like, um...experimental.
It's like, "I'm going
to build something.
"I'll try a few pieces out.
I'll iterate and do that."
So one of the things
I'm seeing is that
we're doing the same thing
with specifications now.
OpenSocial is a way
of defining
social infrastructure
for the web at its--
at its heart.
And what that means is
a bunch of APIs
for representing
common operations
usually around social things.
So there are four primary
operations there.
There's who--
profile information
about people
and connections
between people.
So we've got
a fairly well-defined set
of profile specification
which also maps
to the portable contact stuff.
It's activities,
things people do,
so an event stream over time
that's labeled by who did it
and what they did.
There's a data persistence
API for OpenSocial,
which is again
coupled to people,
so you can store small amounts
of data about people
and do query back to get
the same data items
associated with the friends
of the person
that you're looking at.
So it's basically solving
the rather messy database
join problem
of "Tell me about his person
and their friends."
You're delegating that
to there.
And the fourth one is
sending messages.
It's, "I'd like to send
something to this person."
So those are
the sort of four key APIs.
But the--the point is
to have a layer of abstraction
between the container sites
that are custodians
of social data
that have rich sets
of information
about people and
the connections between them
and the ability to do
this stuff,
and an application that is
focused on a particular task
and doesn't want to have
to replicate that host stuff.
Whereas for any given
application,
you can almost always
augment it
and make it more interesting
by connecting it to people
and to people you know.
Or even just connecting it
to information about you
that you're willing
to share.
If it's--if I know
where you are,
that's a useful thing.
If I know other places
you've lived,
that's also useful.
I can potentially
connect you
to information
about those places, too.
There are lots of things
that--that--
that can make the app more
useful and more intelligent
by drawing on context,
but the problem is having
to declare the context
to the application
each time is very annoying.
So being able to draw
on the context
you've already
established elsewhere
is the sort of key
to OpenSocial.
And so we specify these
different pieces of it
and have APIs for doing that.
You know, the key for me
for a spec
is that people interoperate
without knowing
of each other's existence
just because they're writing
to a common spec.
If you--you know,
if you do that--
if that happens, then you know
you got something right.
It was a Korean developer,
iDetail, who came to visit.
They were in the States,
and they said,
"Can we come and talk
about a proposition?"
I said sure.
I was expecting to pitch
to someone.
I was expecting to say,
"OpenSocial's
a wonderful thing.
You should build this as part
of your social network."
And they said, "We've already
built it."
Neuberg: Oh, that's great.
Marks: It was like--
I was like, "Oh!"
"Yeah, look, we use OpenID
and log in here.
"and we put
an OpenSocial container.
Oh, and here's our developer
site in Korean
that explains how other
people can build gadgets."
And I was like...
okay, that was good.
So that was my sort of moment
where I said,
"Yeah, we're a real standard."
Neuberg: That's a real nice
validation.
Marks: That's like, yeah,
this is where we are.
We keep seeing that,
you know.
As we go around the world
talking about this stuff,
we keep finding more
and more developers
who are already there
and building on that.
And that's what makes
the web work.
You know, the fact
that any web site anywhere
can publish something
and everyone else can read it.